PROFESSOR: Hi everyone.
Welcome back.
So today, I'd like
to tackle a problem
in numerical integration of ODEs
specifically on Euler's method.
And the problem we're
interested in considering today
is the ODE y prime equals
y squared minus xy.
And we're interested in
integrating the solution
that starts at y of zero
is equal to negative 1
using a step size of 0.5.
And we want to
integrate it to y of 1.
And then for the
second part, we're
interested in if our
first step of integration
either overestimates
or underestimates
the exact solution.
So I'll let you think about this
and work it out for yourself,
and I'll come back in a moment.
Hi everyone.
Welcome back.
So as I mentioned before,
this is a problem in numerics.
And specifically, whenever
you're given an ODE,
you can almost
always numerically
integrate it on a computer.
And this is quite possibly
the simplest algorithm
for numerical integration.
So specifically,
what we do is we
take the left-hand side,
the derivative, y prime,
and we approximate it using a
very simple finite difference
formula.
So if I take y prime and
approximate it as y of n
plus 1 minus y of n divided by
h, where h is the step size,
then I can approximate
the continuous ODE
using this simple formula.
So here h as I mentioned
is the step size.
f, in this case, is the
right-hand side of the ODE.
And we see that y of n plus
1 minus y of n divided by h
is an approximation to y prime.
In addition, we
can also write down
x of n plus 1 is just
equal to x of n plus h.
And I'm using
subscripts n here just
to denote the step
of the algorithm.
So for part A, we're
asked to integrate
the solution-- it starts at y
of zero is equal to negative 1--
to y of 1.
So what this means for part A
is we want x of zero to be zero,
and we want y of zero
to be negative 1.
Now to further integrate this
equation, the quickest way
to do it, especially if
you're in a test scenario,
is to build a table.
So a nice table to
build is one that
has a column n, x of n, y of n.
I'm going to write f of n.
f of n is to denote f
evaluated at x of n and y of n.
And then, it's also useful
to write down h times f of n
because the quantity
h times f of n
comes up in the
addition of y of n
plus 1 is equal to y of
n plus h times f of n.
And in the problem
under consideration,
I'm just going to fill
in the first two columns
because they're the easiest.
We have n is equal
to 0, 1 and 2.
X of n is starting off at zero.
So x of zero is zero.
x of 1 is going to be 0.5.
And then, x of 2 is equal to 1.
In addition, we're also
told that y of zero
is equal to negative 1.
And now for f of n, I'll
just use the side here,
what's f of zero going to be?
Well, it's going to be y of
zero minus x of zero y of zero.
So this gives us 1 and 0.
So we can fill in a 0.1 here,
which means that h times f of 1
is going to be 0.5.
And now with h of f of
n, we can fill in y of 1.
So y of 1 is just going
to be y of zero plus 0.5.
And y of zero is negative 1.
So this is going
to be negative 0.5.
Now, we need to fill in f of 1.
So this is going to be y of 1
squared minus x of 1 y of 1.
Now y of 1 squared, this
is negative 0.5 squared.
x of 1 is 0.5.
And y of 1 is,
again, negative 0.5.
So this gives us one
quarter plus one quarter,
which together is just 0.5.
So we have 0.5 in
this square now.
And then h times 0.5 is 0.5
squared, which is just 0.25.
Now y of 2 is just going to
be y of 1 plus h times f of 1.
So we know h of f of
1 is 0.25, and y of 1
is just negative 0.5.
So this is going to
be negative 0.25.
And we note that this is the
answer we're looking for.
So just to conclude, our
approximation y of 2,
which is approximately
y evaluated at 1,
is going to be negative 0.25.
So for part B, we're asked does
our approximation negative 0.25
overestimate or underestimate
the actual exact solution
of the ODE?
Now, in general,
what you want to do
is you want to take
the second derivative.
However, for this
problem, we're only
going to consider
the first step.
So our first step, does it
overestimate or underestimate
the exact solution?
And to do this,
what we want to do
is we want to take a
look at the concavity.
So we want to look
at y double prime.
So y double prime is going
to be d by dx of y prime.
And we know from the ODE y
prime is y squared minus xy.
So I can work this
out to be 2y y prime,
just using the chain rule,
minus y minus x y prime.
And at the first step, we're
interested in evaluating
this quantity at the
point x equals zero,
y is equal to negative 1.
So this is the first step.
So at x is equal to zero,
y is equal to negative 1,
this simplifies to
minus 2y prime plus 1.
This term right here drops off.
And y prime specifically is
going to be y squared minus xy.
So we get 2-- y squared is going
to be 1-- minus zero plus 1.
So together, this is
going to give us minus 1.
And we note that this
is less than zero.
So we've just shown
that the concavity
at our starting point, x equals
zero, y is equal to negative 1
is less than zero.
So what this means is that our
initial approximation is going
to overestimate the solution.
We can see that it's going
to overestimate it just
by a quick sketch.
For example, if I
were to plot y and x,
we're starting off at this
point, x is equal to zero,
y is equal to negative 1.
So this is y(0) is
equal to negative 1.
We know the exact
solution's increasing,
and it's concave down
because the second derivative
is negative 1.
And by Euler's formula,
what we're doing is
we're approximating the
solution using a tangent line
at this point.
So we can see that our
approximate solution
when we take one step
to go from here to here,
so this is x of zero, this is x
of 1, our solution which is now
going to be y of 1 here is
going to overestimate the curve.
And the reason it overestimates
it, I'll just reiterate again,
is because our solution
is concave down.
So this concludes the problem.
And just to reiterate, when
dealing with Euler's method,
the best thing to do is just
to build a table like this.
And you can quickly work it out.
Secondly, if you're
asked questions
on if your numerical solution
overestimates or underestimates
the exact solution,
typically what you want to do
is you want to look
at the concavity.
And then, you can
always just sketch
a quick diagram on
the back of a notepad
to see if the solution
overestimates or underestimates
the exact solution.
So I'd like to conclude here.
And I'll see you next time.